I think Trump needs a relationship where
the other person wants nothing from him
and it's a low-key relationship that
nobody knows nobody needs to know it's
off the Record never interviews never
public never tweeting it's nothing that
is the most valuable relationship for
him today and I don't know if he has it
I don't think that's that's such an
interesting point Pat because I don't
think he's well if you had to guess what
kind of person would be a person that he
would be able to sit in a room and be
like yo bro like what's going on are you
okay like some normal people get a
psychiatrist who would Donald Trump be
able to I don't even think Pat there oh
there's always people there